[Musique]
donc bon soir à toutes et à tous
ce soir je m'appelle greta lawson gallus
j'ai 28 ans et mon parcours
professionnel comme tant d'autres comme
sans doute les vôtres mais rien si je ne
vous raconte pas d'abord une histoire
personnelle
donc merci permettez moi de vous parler
de cette femme qui dans la fin de sa
vingtaine et marié est déjà mère de
quelques enfants cette femme s'appelle
de vie dovi et revendeuse de fournitures
scolaires à lomé et son étalage à
limiter à peine à joindre les deux bouts
c'est alors qu'une de ses tantes qui
propose de revendre du tissu apps qui
est déjà présent sur le marché togolais
dans ces années-là des années soixante
dix le dissez l'édile est simple dovi
achète une quantité prédéfinie de tissus
qu'elle revend elle revient payer ses
dettes et repart avec un autre stock est
alors que de lui découvre le monde du
commerce en gros quel affûte son oeil
pour le tissu wax et surtout pour tous à
trois ses talents de femmes d'affaires
qui jouent là surtout très bien la
connaître ne sont pas des moindres
deauville alors que le tour du togo
pendant plus d'une dizaine d'années en
vendant et achetant du tissu mais
l'opportunité qu'il aidera l'emmènera à
cotonou au bénin pour acheter son tout
premier container du tissu wax elle ne
serait plus du bénin et au sénégal en
côte d'ivoire puis la chine et l'inde
toujours sur la route du wax en
transformant ce qui n'était que des
opportunités en énorme succès les femmes
c'est ma grand-mère et parce qu'elle a
réussi à instiller les valeurs pour
entreprendre dans chacun de ses enfants
y compris ma mère et mes tantes de vie
et ses héritières sont mes premières
références quand je parle
d'entrepreneuriat ou des réalités que
représente le parcours d'entrepreneuriat
elles ont écrite le début de mon
histoire
j'ai donc mai à lomé de parents togolais
béninois
mon père qui est dans la salle ce soir
et banquier à la retraite aujourd'hui ma
mère est commerçante elle aussi dans la
salle ce soir face à voir ma mère je
dois tout grâce à elle j'ai grandi dans
le panneau avec des femmes commerçantes
à l'éthique de travail impeccable et
encore des souvenirs très vite deux
moments passés au marché à prendre le
nom des tissus et le coloris pour les
deuils pour les mariages et même à
compter de l'argent
peut-être parce que j'étais imprégné cet
environnement dès mon plus jeune âge que
je suis devant vous aujourd'hui
ici nous regarde ça ma mère j'ai fait
des études de management pour stratégie
en haut rhin avant de rentrer
m'installer définitivement au togo en
2015 en fin d'année 2015 grâce à une
très belle opportunité professionnelle
ou le mentorat d'une entreprise
extraordinaire
j'espère qu'il est là ce soir se
reconnaîtra le premier projet s'appelle
base dans la peine
bazin pas une marque de vêtements et
d'accessoires qui met un accent sur sa
confection 100% made in togo
le deuxième projet crazy trim est le
tout premier glace
les un projet crazy crime qui voit le
jour en 2017 et le tout premier glacier
spécialisé dans les glaces coulé au togo
enfin mon dernier projet en est au lit
quand ils nous opposent une restauration
multiculturelle et sun et privilégie les
produits locaux comme vous avez pu le
déduire de mon histoire je suis issu de
trois générations d'entrepreneurs
bien que les fondements d'entrepreneurs
elles sont les mêmes
le monde est en constante mutation donc
il faut absolument s'adapter si on veut
saisir les nouvelles opportunités
représente le monde des affaires
si je devais faire tirer des leçons
on va dire de mes quelques années
d'expérience entreprenariale je dirais
qu'il est important de faire confiance à
son idée il faut collaborer avec ses
pairs il faut prendre possession et
utiliser tous les outils que nous avons
à disposition aujourd'hui grâce aux
nouvelles technologies
et enfin pour développer son
adaptabilité
à l'ère de l'entrepreneur moderne comme
j'aime à l'appeler votre idée peut venir
de tout et de rien elle peut être le
fruit de votre talent elle peut être le
résultat d'une inspiration vous avez vu
dans un magazine à la télé havre après
une conversation elle peut aussi venir
de très loin
ou simplement répondre à un problème que
vous rencontrez dans votre quotidien
dans votre environnement au quotidien un
très bel exemple de ça et le concept de
glace rouler en 2016
les découpes ce concept aux états unis
pendant les vacances et je suis choqué
prouve que c'est génial et divertissant
c'est original et tout eu envie de
l'emporter et l'adapter aux saveurs
locales que j'aime surtout dans ce
concept c'est qu'il est asiatique et
j'ai découvert aux états unis que je
m'inspire des recettes de glace
traditionnelles européennes et que je
peut l'adapter en fait au bout de chez
nous on y ajoutant les gourmandises
comme le haras lui et le coq en dha ou
encore le nougat pour ceux qui
connaissent
il est important de retenir et qu'il
faut faire confiance en votre idée il
faut miser sur vous même parce que votre
idée au ppte est la prochaine grande
entreprise dont le togo a besoin par
exemple une fois que votre idée bien
assise et que vous commencez à
entreprendre
vous réaliserez assez rapidement que
l'écosystème de votre entreprise est
vital donc des parties prenantes qui
sont les fournisseurs et clients ou
encore les salariés valoriser le
networking horizontale
pour malek torkington horizontale par
bon c'est un lien gagnant gagnant va
dire entre acteurs économiques
mettons vous êtes le meilleur dans votre
domaine dans un secteur particulier
l'idée c'est de créer des connexions
avec d'autres personnes qui sont des
figures clefs aussi de leur domaine
respectif comme ça avec cette
collaboration intelligente créer une
synergie qui vous permet d'atteindre des
objectifs plus vite et plus efficacement
je me rappelle que quand je suis rentré
au togo et que je voulais lancer la
première société
j'ai été confronté à ce problème que
beaucoup d'entre nous connaisse enfin
ceux qui essaient d'entreprendre au togo
c'est qu'on n'a pas vraiment accès à
toutes les informations
tout est un peu chaotique les
administrations publiques sont pas
vraiment du goût dans le heads et alors
que je me rappelle que mon ami d'enfance
yannick qui est aussi vraie salle ce
soir à créer une société un cabinet est
en outre a pour objectif de suivre les
petites pme et les aider à se structurer
dès le début donc j'appelle yannick on
fait un petit meeting du me pose plein
de questions quelle est ta vision est ce
que tu vas dans cinq ans qu'est ce tu
veux faire etc
il revient avec des propositions
détaillées sur les réglementations en
vigueur pour telle option la fiscalité
pour celles telle option
donc je fais le choix et deux semaines
après j'ai créé ma première société
on travaille chronique m'a permis non
seulement d'avoir une bande temps
considérable dans mes recherches et
surtout d'apprendre et de savoir un peu
plus sur la création d'entreprise otomo
fait que demain j'aurai plus besoin de
yannick finalement une autre façon
collaborer pour moi aussi c'est d'être
ouvert en fin de compte diversité qu'est
ce que vous côtoyez au quotidien est-ce
que c'est toujours les mêmes personnes
où est-ce qu'ils sont différents moi
j'aime côtoyer des gens d'horizons
différents deux tranches d'âge
différentes les milieux sociaux
différents de genres différents
parce que ces personnes représentent vos
clients potentiels du caissier au
gardien au serveur tout le monde a créé
menu enfin une carte avec des produits
qui leur semblait donc de la conception
alisation ce cas la commercialisation
et devinez quoi avec cette carte on a
fait les meilleures ventes de l'année
2010 neuf donc investissez dans vos
collaborateurs
[Applaudissements]
une fois que nous parlons
d'entrepreneuriat moderne
nous devons absolument parler de
nouvelles technologies aujourd'hui elle
bouleverse l'occasion de vivre toutes
façons de travailler
on a littéralement de nouveaux métiers
de nouveaux marchés de nouveaux moyens
de paiement de nouveaux moyens
d'interagir avec nos clients qui sont
les plus intimes plus direct donc l'idée
c'est de savoir comment s'en servir
vous savez je vous emmène à mai avec moi
en 2011
ma cousine l'audience et talentueuse
médias dessine depuis qu'elle en âge de
tenir un crayon
nous sommes en vacances à lomé et il lui
vient l'idée en fin de compte de créer
un accessoire inspirées des tendances
parisienne mais infuser d'une touche
résolument togolaise et crée donc un
accessoire qui connaît un grand succès
immédiatement
nous voulons créer de la demande donc
pour rentrer à lomé nous un petit stock
nous revenons à paris et là on se
demande comment est-ce qu'on va le
vendre
on n'a pas les moyens d'avoir une
boutique physique à paris on n'a pas les
moyens à même de faire un site internet
et là on se rappelle que tout le monde
est sur facebook donc on ouvre une page
facebook en en 2011
est super simple on prend des photos des
produits on les met sur la page avec le
nom du produit le prix et on commence à
vendre des fentes et des remises en
mains propres
ils sont en région parisienne ça vous
permet aussi d'avoir leur feedback de
parler de la culture d'entreprise et
quand ils sont à l'étranger
ils nous paient 10 à paypal et on leur
envoie par la poste
à ce moment là on réalise avec ma
cousine loggia on étudiants qu on a 20
ans mais à partir de votre salon notre
ordinateur
on peut créer et maintenir un business
[Applaudissements]
la technologie est aussi synonyme
d'information le fonctionnent beaucoup
sur les recherches
instruisez vous aujourd'hui à vannes moi
c'est votre entreprise instruisez vous
faites fait le travail de recherche pour
avoir des bases solides et une fois que
l'entreprise ait lancé continue de faire
le travail de recherche pour essayer de
garder cet avantage concurrentiel que
vous avez c'est très important parce que
les concurrents arrivent tous les jours
enfin les technologies sont aussi les
algorithmes aujourd'hui les algorithmes
font le travail que nous faisions un peu
plus rapidement peut-être plus
précisément et donc l'idée c'est de se
dire si mettons l'algorithme fait 25%
mon travail qu'est ce que je fais de ce
nouveau gain de temps
comment est ce que je montre la plus
value comment est ce que je sorte du lot
finalement donc ces questions ne mènent
donc à la dernière leçon tirer mes
expériences entrepreneuriales et
peut-être la plus importante selon loin
l'adaptabilité
on définit souvent l'adaptabilité notre
capacité à s'adapter à pivoter dans un
environnement qui change a si rapidement
et fréquemment moi ma définition
l'adaptabilité et bien évidemment oui
cette capacité à apprendre de nouvelles
choses mais aussi de trouver ce qui est
pertinent en fin de compte dans les
nouvelles connaissances que voulait
apprendre et surtout le plus important
réussir à désapprendre et connaissance
absolue
si vous avez l'adaptabilité vous réalise
rapidement que vous avez besoin
d'utiliser votre intuition humaines pour
résoudre des problèmes par exemple peut
utiliser votre créativité pour
responsabiliser et même communiquer avec
vos collaborateurs vous pouvez utiliser
de l'empathie je pense que j'ai
perfectionné enfin pas perfectionner je
pense que j'ai compris l'importance on
va dire de l'adaptabilité
en 2012 nous et par les balles de notre
marque de vêtements réseau appelle donc
une fois que le projet est lancé que ça
fonctionne qu on est contente on décide
de rentrer à lomé pour produire à lomé
faire du made in togo parce que on
connaît l'importance et la richesse et
surtout le savoir faire les artisans
togolais et on veut vraiment mettre ça
en avant donc on arrive à l'onu on
travaille quelques artisans mais très
vite on se rend compte que c'est
compliqué
les points de couture sont pas forcément
respectée et délais sont pas forcément
respectée
je me rappelle même apple même d'un
artisan qui avaient l'habitude de se
cacher dans son atelier tu m'as sous
sont tous la machine quelle nouvelle est
arrivée parce qu'il est pas produit dans
les temps donc on était vraiment dans
cette phase-là de là qu'est ce qu'on
fait à ce moment là on a décidé
d'utiliser notre de s'adapter et
d'utiliser nos intuitions humaine donc
on est parti voir nos artisans
on a discuté avec eux enfin qu'on a
trouvé la source du problème
on a décidé d'investir dans un v6 dans
les formations
on a investi dans le partage de
connaissances on a mis en place des
procédés ou les procédures comme le
contrôle de qualité par exemple et
surtout on aa si cette idée d'un
partenariat gagnant gagnant entre les
artisans qui sont les parties prenantes
de la marque et la marque
aujourd'hui par exemple plusieurs de nos
artisans avec qui nous avons commencé en
2011 par leur propre compte avec leurs
ateliers leurs apprentis et même leurs
machines à coudre et aujourd'hui nous
sous-traitons certains de nos
productions à ces artisans là en tant
que collaborateurs indépendants
dans notre société on associe certains
critères on va dire certains traits de
caractère à l'adaptabilité
ça va être par exemple la flexibilité la
curiosité ou même les compétences en
résolution de problèmes mais la vérité
c'est qu'on peut tous travaillé à
devenir adaptable on peut commencer par
exemple par laisser les distractions les
mettre de côté
facile à dire qu'à faire on peut poser
des questions qui font peur ils font en
sorte on sort de notre zone de confort
faut essayer de normaliser la peur on
peut par exemple être curieux et on va
encore être ouvert aux possibilités
considère l'entrepreneuriat comme une
façon de participer activement à
l'économie de mon pays à mon échelle en
tout cas qu'à la création d'emplois la
valorisation des ressources naturelles
et surtout l'innovation
drake entreprenait a beaucoup changé
depuis l'époque de ma grand mère les
kodans changer la façon de faire a
changé donc pour m'adapter en créant les
entreprises aient choisi de faire
confiance à mes idées de collaborer avec
mes pairs d'apprendre à utiliser et de
mettre en pratique tous les outils qui
sont aujourd'hui disponibles grâce aux
nouvelles technologies et surtout le
travail constamment seront
l'adaptabilité
avant de vous laisser j'aimerais qu'on
semble en réfléchissent à quelque chose
comment voulons nous le monde de demain
autour de nous quels sont aujourd'hui
les secteurs dans lesquels nous devons
dans lesquelles nous devons mettre un
accent par exemple pour améliorer notre
environnement de demain dans nos pays
dans nos communautés sur notre continent
est ce la santé l'éducation l'accès au
financement
les quadras culture faites votre choix
et surtout entreprenait merci
[Applaudissements]
mais